joe-joe season two is upon us yes what
are you guys gonna do to up the ante
this season you know it's actually
really fun taking something out of the
show to give more time to show the kids
which I was at rapping about because I
love the performances of their dancing
and they're lifting and their creativity
like it's just unbelievable
Jojo see wah spilling on season 2 of lip
sync battle shorties and she's giving
Edie an exclusive tour of the whole set
no it's not dangerous at all just make
yourself a hole all right here we go
we're doing it how much time do you
spend here a little too often yeah it's
just so bright yeah like for like
awesome
Jojo co-hosts the Nickelodeon show with
Nick Cannon yeah Wow
what about you and Nick are we gonna see
any collaborations this season I mean
Nick he wrote this song you're gonna
have to ask are you interviewing Nick
yep you're gonna give me all that give
me a little bit on there just just ask
him Jojo can I get a Bobo he wrote this
song
not even wrote just literally sang it
once yeah has not stopped since the
first day of shootings like 30 times a
show I'm talking like literally just
non-stop Jojo can I get a Bobo what does
that even mean my number-one next hit
I'm gonna open my interview with that
yeah just open it Jojo and I did a Bobo
I'm really off on this I want to go
check out this room yes I'll take you on
a tour gosh I've carefully carefully
saving Jojo see why this room is all my
favorite I think it's cool it's like a
50/50 we're gonna go out here cuz I know
that there's like a whole makeup station
situation and makeup there's dance rooms
there's candy trucks
there's people how long does it take you
to get ready for the show everybody
actually it's funny I'm on an average
when I get ready for any sort of event
or a show or anything it takes about an
hour and a half but for shorty is
legally I can only be on set for nine
and a half hours and to make all the
hours work I only get 45 minutes of hair
and makeup so my time is cut in half
there is really cool you let me show you
that I do what I got I got there's no
echo in one place here it's cool last
period they had this echo echo oh but
wait so you hear the echo right here but
then you go right here there's no echo I
feel like we're gonna have to take a
picture in front of this side yeah yeah
yeah can we go check out your dressing
room
yeah around out so I guess I'm gonna
join up I have to warn you there's a
little furry phone your dog is here yeah
she's been chilling outside all day this
bow this bow deserves yeah that's my
where's my little munchkin at very cool
go on I'll take you and I'll take you in
[Music]
okay I'm not gonna tell Nick but who
keeps their dressing room cleaner I know
you've never been in the last year I
went in his and definitely you that one
is pretty organized yeah we yeah we keep
it clean in here we keep everything on
nice and then display because we just we
love it and we take pride in it and so
yeah fun thing to keep clean and before
we wrap this up I do want to know I feel
like you have so many celebrity fans who
reaches out to you who's ready for that
Jojo Co collaboration I don't know how
to collaboration but celebrities who I
do know that their kids are fans is Gwen
Stefani which was the coolest thing ever
I need a Gwen Stefani Jojo co-op
collaboration tell me about it yeah tell
me about it no she is awesome she's
beautiful yeah maybe with a Nick Cannon
getting involved in that too that would
be fun that would be fun I'm trying to
think if there's any other I do is just
a magazine article of Suri Cruise and
she had a ginger Bowen so that was
really really cool Tori Spelling she
came up to me at dinner with her kids
that was crazy baby spice Emma Bunton
yeah she was here she came to Shorty's
her kids are big fans so many so many
people the list just goes on and on I'm
just I'm waiting for Kim Kardashian
Kourtney Kardashian I'm sure their kids
are big fans that would be my dream also
do LMFAO's kids I mean come on they're
like seven-five are you have to watch
Grey's Anatomy the biggest fan there is
baby tell people three reasons why they
should tune in to the next season three
reasons why you should tune in to the
next season a because it's awesome
beanie because it's awesome and thing
cuz it's awesome oh just kidding
Amy because it's awesome be because the
performances are just so next level and
see because there are so many surprises
that you are not gonna want to miss
[Music]